what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are about to do a first
time watching for a film that has been
recommended our way quite a few times
and that is Tommy Boy and I am joined by
my great great friend fellow reject
salamander Sally Sally Lamonica all the
way in the east coast Sally how are you
I'm great heck yeah that's exciting to
hear now listen we got a couple things
to mention first off please leave a like
that really helps out this video quite a
bit secondly um Sally I want you to use
this opportunity to plug what you got
going on right now I mentioned it on our
community post I want you to talk about
it really quick why thank you Gregory
Alba you're welcome so I've been a fan
of Spider-Man forever even though I've
been doing the Marvel movie marathon I
have never missed a Spider-Man movie I
decided to make a Spider-Man fan film
from the perspective of Mary Jane Watson
courtesy of the real rejects fans it
wasn't my idea it was your guys's idea
like six years ago we are doing an
Indiegogo campaign to raise the rest of
the money I've shot four scenes already
using my own money we are just asking
for a little help if anyone would like
to donate I'm sure the link will be in
the description for the campaign and
there is a teaser trailer based off the
four scenes that we've already shot so
that's my little Spiel it's looking
great so if you guys want to go
contribute it would be uh I really
appreciate it even on my end I would
appreciate it too and Greg might be in
it I don't know uh it might be who knows
we'll see what happens Spider-Man was
already taken so I don't know what role
could be left for me anyway uh we're
gonna move on to Tommy Boy right now
very very much uh thematically in tune
with Spider-Man and as always uh
full-length to action watch long as we
stick it with your own copy for Tommy
Boy Bilbo for super sexy Rejects and
over there we cover exclusively many
shows with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included Sally you ready to rock
this boat I am so ready because I love
both of these actors I can't wait to
laugh my butt off buttocks off buttocks
off
[Music]
Mommy hurry up you're gonna be late for
school again
Lauren Michaels from SNL
[Music]
that makes sense
yeah actually he's probably on SNL this
time
[Music]
damn Tommy Boy grew up rich
you're pathetic shut up Richard you're
late too buddy thank you
hurry Tommy this is like Spider-Man
trying to catch them
whoa he grew up in like a second
[Laughter]
[Music]
runs pretty fast for a big guy
honestly he's killing it
is he hitting his head against
ugh
brings back memories
Alfred Hancock
Herbie
oh my God I I passed
that's college for sure
I wish we'd known each other this is a
little awkward
I'll probably go back and work at my
dad's loading dock like always I love
all you guys
especially you
know
that one dude looked really nervous yeah
he like panicked for a second so where's
my dad I thought he's gonna meet me at
the airport he was at the airport this
morning but you weren't on the plane
yeah I guess you should have called I
did call earlier where when was that or
later when then it's
year I finally graduated yeah and just a
shade under a decade too all right
oh that has to be you
oh my God you know I have never grown up
on Chris Farley
really a lot of this feels
very different to me
and maybe she's like two SNL sketches of
Chris he's very over the top but that's
like his thing you know hey would you
mind not eating in the car it's kind of
a rule
hey what's new in the old gang from high
school I don't know Tommy I didn't
really like the old gang from high
school you're a stiff David Spade
yeah
Mom you're talking about a huge loan
maybe instead of borrowing it should
take on a partner no no no there's
always has been always will be a family
firm
my grandfather found him 21. my father
kept it running during the Depression
my son will run it hey Dad
hey
[Music]
look alive low bridge
oh my God
damn he sells those really well yeah he
does
what is this thing it's a buffer I take
oil filter that needs smoothing and
help yourself
oh
[Music]
this is nice distance
everyone is a bad enabler here but he
knows their names this is awesome I I
need fresh capital for material for a
new Workforce before I can turn these
machines on look out oh no what have you
done
[Applause]
why let's go yes sir
this is Dad loves him yeah good son
that's my name yeah that's your new
office now college grad hey there's even
a fridge this is great you can put six
packs of soda in here
put candy bars in the freezer anything
that you want to keep cool
you watch
thank you
it's called reading top to bottom left
to right group words together as a
sentence take Tylenol for any headaches
might offer any cramps
it's weird seeing David Spade play such
a straight edge yeah it's true
it feels like a real character yeah is
that Rob White
oh my God it is
[Music]
holy schnikes
whoa are you sure it's not your stepmom
are you Tommy I'm Tommy this is an
uncomfortable situation I got an
announcement to make
Tom I've I've asked Beverly to be my
wife
whoa
[Laughter]
what'd she say
he's coming here today for the wedding
Tommy but my son is going to be your new
brother I'm gonna have a brother
it's like Step Brothers
speak of the devil oh
my God that scared me brother I'm Paul
you must be Tommy Brothers don't shake
hands we're brothers got a fun
[Laughter]
at least not what I've seen
that's very you Greg
if I sent a picture of your mom to some
of my buddies at school she'd definitely
be boner of the month
ah perfect which one you want huh huh
okay
[Laughter]
is this your first time yeah Tommy it is
you're gonna remember this the rest of
your life can't believe you've never
been cow tipping before oh what you put
your shoulder into her and you bush
and they fall over
[Music]
those look like real cows they are real
cows that's scary yeah
me my turn over here these shoes are
Italian
off with cats this sword is going
to Columbus it's a one-day delivery but
you've got to mark down for two Georgia
not Columbus Ohio maybe you should go
back to college for another seven years
and study a globe oh that's messed up
Michelle Brock chaperel high oh yeah I
remember I sat next to you in history I
remember your brother Dwayne we used to
go to Safeway all the time and get
caught trying to steal Donuts he's a cop
I'd better not uh I have what doctors
call a little bit of a weight problem I
used to grab bear claws as a kid two at
a time and I'd get them launched right
in this region here how about some
coffee I'd love some he's so endearing I
don't know how but he is oh yeah
it's got a real boyish quality about him
yeah something about that getting old
and being alone
yeah
it's cool you know I just want you to be
happy Richard seems so jealous of Tommy
yeah I Now Pronounce You man and wife
you may kiss the bride yeah lay one on
her
[Music]
so this is what it's like when you get
to a 10 year old wedding party oh no
inside joke people you don't know what
I'm talking about
laughs
this movie couldn't be as entertaining
as that I promise
[Music]
is that him really singing
I don't know I
I'm still in shock this is happening
that's like great wow he's really just
nailing it
ah
what Dad somebody call 9-1-1 it is like
your wedding oh
sorry damn
that's tragic
it's a good transition when things get
too good in movies
even though Tom is gone
you'll remain in our lives forever oh my
God was he poisoned
oh I didn't think about that I was
thinking Rob Lowe did it to get the
money or some yeah he looked like a
psychopath that's what I say
oh Richard actually feels bad for him
that scent is getting to me that took
such a turn what the hell wow you're
right in the middle of a musical number
I don't think I've ever seen anything
like that what happened
thank you
foreign
he's just a lost boy I know
one told me we were watching Schindler's
List
I'm gonna really miss him
my father was a great guy
yeah oh my God why am I crying
that's sad it's just sad because he died
of a heart attack in real life
need a little wind here no you need to
drop a couple hundred pounds flip
Rascals I guess that's your theory
I just realized the boat was like
yeah
she's really low on his language in
front of the lady Punk
and jam it over up your ass
those guys keep interrupting us I'm
sorry
[Music]
did I know where you live and I've seen
where you sleep I swear to everything
only that your mothers will cry when
they see what I've done to you
Marry That Woman tummy yep just she's
the one
that was awesome
this movie has more of a heart than I
expected I know Frankie if we sell well
our values still high everyone who owns
stock in this company stands to make a
lot of money that of course includes you
Mrs Callahan now that you and Tommy are
the primary shareholders
[Music]
if this Factory goes under the whole
town goes on and that's when those come
in
and laying their trick money down twenty
dollars to pay the rent maybe instead
I'll spend it on the
oh my God
I'll give you everything I've got my
house the stock then will you give us
that loan you just want to hand over
your inheritance right my dad said the
new pads were the future of Callahan but
who's going to sell them
I will oh you got this time
he's running around doing a little
behind
us once during the War I visited a
prostitute in my life has been a living
hell ever since
I don't know much about this stuff
but he does
that's right Richard knows more about
brake pads than anyone in here odd balls
bad idea I don't think anyone could help
Baby Huey out there on the road you have
a better suggestion
cutting right to the chase
see I thought if he was jealous of him
he'd want to be promoted so
oh I can actually hear you're getting
fatter
what are the three grades of Callahan
brake pads personal commercial and uh
Agricultural and what is our carrying
charge for all the merchandise in the
warehouse one and a half percent I knew
that why can't I remember it
this is the person uses ten percent of
their brain how much do you use one and
a half percent
[Laughter]
he's like four and 40 at the same time
are you ready yeah sorry I'm ready hey
does this suit made me look fat no no
your face does
ouch
all right now it's sale time so remember
we don't take no no from anyone
take no for an answer oh yeah we don't
take no for an answer we'll take no
for video
no okie dokie oh got your thing
maybe I just like to add that the
spectrometer readout on the nickel
cadmium alloy mix indicates a good Rich
strobe and fade decreasing incidence of
wear to the pressure plate if you could
just oh little fella you're not speaking
my language yeah you lack relatability
yeah our new brake pads are really cool
you're not even going to believe it
let's say you're driving along the road
with your family and you're driving
along
then all of a sudden there's a truck
tire in the middle of the road and you
hit the brakes
just
now let's see what happens when you're
driving with the other guys
you're driving along
the back seat I gotta go to the bathroom
Daddy not now damn it truck tired
I can't stop
no what have you done Tommy you were so
close we screaming oh my God
oh my legs here comes a meat wagon
oh no you can see Davis may try to keep
a straight face the whole time new guys
in the corner puking his guts out
because you want to save a couple extra
pennies and to me it doesn't get out
do you validate no
that escalated beautifully yes hey
chiefy could you tell me how far it is
to Davenport
22 miles okay I can't find it on this
map well get yourself a new map
just reverse the car a little bit
[Music]
what is wrong with you
it's got to be on the map Davenport I
mean because you say it's 22 miles away
and you're really smart
[Music]
it's like cow tipping
oh my God
that's map of Illinois which we're in on
the border of Iowa which is where
Davenport is 22 miles away
you're in the wrong State get yourself a
new map
he was right the whole time hey why
don't you pumping a gas they're all out
they only got diesel better go to the
next station
how do you not notice his door okay
damn you guys are popsicle ow you want
to act like a baby I'll treat you like
one
you're gonna act like a big boy
what oh no they were not daughters
you won't have the company no it's too
bad he didn't leave me any cash you
talked to the banker yeah unfortunately
your stock isn't worth it until they
sell the placement that moment is
rapidly approaching dang it
so they didn't kill him so they are
mother and son
I don't know what's happening
I'll see you Michelle
[Music]
catch it yep
you find them out you won't sell squat
Tommy saved the factory that's the laugh
oh my God
[Laughter]
oh God sprinkle here
anyway
did the brake pads work
fascinating observation Greg maybe he
did lean over to insult me you would
have seen it coming what are we gonna do
can't just leave it here
what just happened hey won't you hurry
you know that thing in the back seat
it's not an air freshener it's a dead
rotting deer carcass
I've been doing business with Callahan
since I hung out my shingle but I don't
like you probably never will
I'm a happy little man and you treat
people like they were idiots yes
before I decide to keep my business with
your place I'd have to come by and have
a look at your new operation
hey I tell you what you can take a good
look at a butcher's ass by sticking your
head up there but wouldn't you rather
take his word for it it's not
get it I quit I can't do this anymore
man no Tommy my whole life sucks I don't
know what I'm doing I don't know where
I'm going my dad just died time I drive
down the road I want to jerk the wheel
and I'm a goddamn bridge in butman
we'll be in touch guys this is
interesting I can't believe he called me
a psycho hey were you in there just now
you are a psycho good God and comb your
hair yeah well I wouldn't say you did
much better I thought you were yes the
deer
ah
I think you're trying to bite me
oh no
[Music]
wow I used a real deer
oh yeah
but that was
awesome yeah but sorry about your car
man
that sucks yo Richard that's your fault
yeah
he was like it's how I fell I was like
then who hit it it's the guarantee that
I make to the American worker
I want your truck to help you get the
job done it's like a Ghostbusters
commercial we haven't made one sale
which means we only have to sell about a
half a million brake pads in the next 10
days or else the Factory's going under
and the one guy that should care about
all this you doesn't you doesn't is not
a sentence
and He does care he's just stupid
don't
that guy in a little card
what is happening okay get off get I'm
serious
[Music]
explaining that I was seen all of his
properties being destroyed
the side eye
yes
[Music]
oh my God
laughs
that's like actually them
oh God
yikes
the brakes work
patience
I'm not my dad that's right you're not
your dad he could sell a ketchup
popsicle to a woman in white glove I
learned everything I know from him I
didn't have a father and he looked out
for me but you there it is hey I'm Big
Tom's son he'll fix everything so I'm
allowed to be a
fine give me your best shot I'll give
you a free one let me have
Captain limpress try again
[Music]
buddy is there a window open I feel a
draft
do it or called your mother
oh my God
songs are a character in the movie
honestly I thought I hit you on the
shoulder
my shoulder doesn't hurt very much but
my face does right here
[Laughter]
boy some chicken wings had really hit
the spot you sure it's closed yep it's
closed
oh
let me tell you why I suck as a Salesman
let's say I go into some guy's office
let's say he's even remotely interested
in buying something well then I get all
excited I'm like
pet is my possible sale yeah I love it I
love my little naughty fat you're
naughty
oh
I killed it
God you're sick I'll go turn the Friars
back on and throw some wings in oh my
God he made this person I did it hey you
got the wings because you were relaxed
so you had confidence your dad had that
he was the best at knowing what people
wanted to hear and what people needed to
hear that's what selling is all about in
a way these people are buying you not
just brake pads yeah it's true they buy
into you
you gotta get people to pity by
yeah
move them emotionally if you're not
talking about a guarantee skip it my
customers need to see that little label
look at them right in the eye hey you
can get a good look at your butcher
you figure you put that little box under
your pillow at night the guarantee fairy
might come by and leave a quarter am I
right Ted how do you know the ferry
isn't a crazy glue sniffer building
model airplanes says the little fairy
well we're not buying it he sneaks into
your house once that's all it takes next
thing you know there's money missing off
the dresser and your daughter's knocked
up I've seen enough oh my God because
they know all they sold you was a
guaranteed piece of that's all it
is isn't it hey if you want me to take a
dump in a box and Mark it guaranteed I
will
you might want to think about buying a
quality product from me okay I'll buy
from you I'll let what
would be good for us I hate this because
I don't know if they're actually related
I know but it just
what does every Factory need
trucks they make stuff they've got to
ship it it's a must stuff the trucks
stop Tommy I prefer if they're mother
and son
yeah I can't picture them as lovers
honestly
she's like tried really hard yes
[Music]
[Applause]
see Psychopaths
not good
yeah
he was gonna shoot that dog I knew he
was Psycho
is homeboy about to pleasure himself
it's not
it's not what the
what were you doing
going over some documents awkward
you knew it hey that's a pretty girl
down there good for her geez I wonder if
she goes out with one of the Yankees
what a random bit since I come so
comfortable
who's your favorite little rascal
alfalfa
or is it Spanky
thinner sinner
I'll buy yes I like what I hear Yes
sounds good by the way could you ever
eat paint chips as a kid
oh God
I'm okay so you can see the mark on the
window
that's impressive yeah
he hurt himself for our benefit
for art tell me that's fabulous your dad
never sold a thousand in Oshkosh uh not
since I've been here it's not about
where you come from Greg
it's about what you do with it she maybe
oh what is that uh ew
that sucks
they're screwed
can you run and pee at the same time
yes it's very it's physically possible
Sally okay and it was a turn I think you
can too
that'd be cool not that I'd ever be in
that situation so let's make a new video
let's see what we can do Tick Tock hack
[Music]
this guy's going to be a human deformity
by the end of the move
it's giving Like Home Alone how messed
up can he look by the end of it I just
wanted to tell you that Tommy's been
talking a lot about you recently and
well
so sweet
you have no idea how much it means
having you in your mom's family
[Laughter]
well between that and the sweetness I'd
say hang on to it oh la la
towels need sleepy
I'll skip it keeping you in my pillow
please go away let me sleep
[Laughter]
hey guess what I just called Autotech
and they decided to make an order that
puts us over the mark yes oh Richard I'm
so happy Hol
t
run away from your feelings
[Music]
oh look at them getting along mm-hmm
your shipments got screwed up in the
computer the wrong Parts went to the
wrong cities now all hell is broken no
believe it
so hard 6 p.m tomorrow
I'll be unemployed
it's not too late no it's just always
lost moment of a movie
they're gonna turn it around we've
actually learned shipping addresses
didn't we yes and they were right when I
put them into my computer I swear how
could maybe if you weren't such a rebel
you could avoid don't worry because I
quit so you won't have to put up with
anything anymore oh no I called about a
ticket to Cuyahoga Falls her name's
Brock right that flight's going through
Columbus let me just call that up for
you
oh
[Music]
excuse me
gotta get them on the Jerry Springer
Show
don't you know we can get busted for
that I'm sorry I did not know that right
now we got a bigger problem that is
Beer's coming back up oh Lord
oh no oh my God
cops damn it Richard the whole car
smells like beer they're never gonna
believe I wasn't drinking when I stopped
the car run out screaming no problem
I go I'm gonna make it seem like it was
something else yeah
oh no
Jeremy roll around on the ground forget
that I'm starting to swell up
I'm allergic to bees me too they're huge
we go to Chicago tell them we're not for
sale he seems like a good guy on TV
he'll understand yeah he's dreaming yeah
all right
you got this Tommy Boy
we're screwed no tickets to Chicago not
even standby there's got to be something
we can do
[Music]
no
you got any money
because I got a plan you're gonna fly
the plane oh my God I had a nice
surprise they said we were going to be
short-handed this leg you
touch Owen could you handle the
announcements okie dokie oh no although
what are the odds of us actually hitting
a leg my money says if anything it's
gonna be a mountain to inflate put it
around your neck and yank down on the
tap
oh my God
[Music]
impressive
this is stressing me out Tommy
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah I'm okay I'm fine I'm fine now
oh my God
that looks painful as an actor
whoa look at this place
that's massive he is the king where is
he where is he
listen up this will only take a second
oh no
he's surrendered what
sir what exactly happened here he came
out of the Shadows behind me and after
he hit me many many times with me
I had to give him my gun you know I've
got kids
Jesus
galahan's a premium name that's what I'm
buying I can make the parts in one of my
factories put them in a Callahan box and
sell them in my stores at a premium
price
[Music]
wow
um
so much production I was gonna say like
there's a lot of stuff there's a lot
oh my God what a reveal don't feel bad
this chain of events was set in motion a
long long time ago you and your
bald-headed friend here you did what you
poor guy
this is Callahan sir Hey sir what
a so-called family deserted me
Michelle's mad at me I lost the factory
the town's going under and I'm out of a
job
could have done without that
when we first started out I thought you
just walked through this like you walk
through everything else but you didn't
your dad would have been proud of you
and you got a friend out of it now I
know it doesn't matter because you have
so many but uh
I don't
oh it's like SpongeBob and Patrick did
you guys know John's really bald what
he wears a toupee yep really no
oh the airport I was going home and I
saw your stepbrother and your stepmother
and he was kissing her so with his
tongue
so
you lied to my dad they're con artists
they suckered him they lied to my dad
[Music]
what is the plan here
why I'm on fire
he's gonna blow up the building
sorry boys hopefully we'll just be in
and out oh my God he's white and uh no
cops wouldn't want things to get messy
that I didn't really see that coming
that he'd pretend to be a terrorist
my your hands move quickly
quickly only when I see something I want
Mrs Callahan
oh that's so gross look at this human
bomb on the news
oh yeah I buy brake pads off him I
thought we were watching cartoons
[Laughter]
right now those workers are in danger
losing their jobs I'll be happy to look
into it I can get a good look at a
T-bone by sticking my head up a bull's
ass but I'd rather take the butcher's
word for it he nailed it this is an
order for half a million Callahan brake
pads to be sold in your stores made by
the American working man for the
American working man
um
smart man it would be my great pleasure
I mean what have I got to lose a great
American product right beat him at his
own game you lost your shares to your
bank you don't even have a right to be
here Steve funny you should bring that
up because I'm not sure that you have
the right to be here oh yes get it girl
how can Beverly be married to Paul and
my dad at the same time what I think it
means is your marriage to my dad was
never legal which also means that
Beverly share still belonged to Tommy
yes I believe that's right Mr Riley I'd
say that's right none of you guys seem
surprised at all yeah I was like um
[Music]
why
want to step over to my club and we'll
grab something to eat
away with this
it's great Tommy thanks
way to go Tommy Kelly kiss her do it
uh
new president of Callahan Otto Tom
Callahan Jr
he went from Tommy Boy to Tommy Mann
ever since I was a kid you people have
been like a family to me
Lewis we built our first Fort together
RT I lost my virginity to your daughter
for crying out loud
you know that as long as I'm around I'm
gonna bust my butt and make sure that
every last 20 I always has a job right
here at Callahan
thumbs up dad got a little problem here
I've been stuck out here for an hour
with no wind again I'm supposed to be at
Michelle's for dinner so if you give me
a little help I'd appreciate it if not
don't worry about it
that a mermaid
it pushes the boat I still love you and
I sure miss you a lot
[Music]
it's me
paint with all the colors the wind I was
thinking that and then you said it I
love it thanks Dad
dad's Pocahontas that's gonna leave a
mark
how cute
oh that was a sweet film
it was a sweet film all right now let's
do an Easter egg breakdown hidden
details all the things the audience
missed Sally take it away
all right
um
first of all the tone
it really start with the tone it doesn't
start with the tone
um no I think uh it's bizarre to me that
this worked because well Chris Farley is
such an amazing actor and like I know he
over that's his thing as he goes over
the top but
um
I don't know like you can there's like a
quote that's like it doesn't have to be
realistic it has it just has to be
believable and I think he just nails
that to a tea like even though none of
it's really realistic he's just so
believable like his eyes just it's I
don't know he's so intense but it works
yeah he's he's very committed
uh yes that's what yeah very committed I
mean I love these kind of whack-a-doodle
zany comedies you know and the
especially these 80s ones that
tend to have like a road trip Vibe and
you you pair up people where like one's
high energy the other is low energy and
then you watch as they morph into
friends by the end of the film I like
that and they're this vulnerabilities
come out yeah yeah and you know like
like I said I I didn't grow up with
Chris Farley you know I feel like if
someone who grows and so I'm not I'm not
I've seen like two sketches of his from
snls one of those classic sketches so I
don't I was like familiar with like kind
of the you know the the the slapstick
um physicalities that he would do but
I've never seen him in like a full-blown
performance so to have this sort of
introduction to uh his work here he he
has this in endearing child-like quality
that makes a character it was like there
are lines that he makes funny that
normally wouldn't be funny but he
finally exactly maybe cheesier like bad
but he somehow still Nails the delivery
on it yeah he's got great delivery and
he's he's he manages to bring a high
level of energy backed with a surprising
sincerity in the way he says things so
this movie is one of those films that
surprisingly works because this could
easily have just been very annoying and
frustrating to sit through but I was
like no this is funny and this has a
really good heart and uh while yeah it's
like it is cartoonish and sketch like
but it's still a real film at the end of
the day with uh still had a storyline
and still had villains I mean it still
had like the classic formula to like a
good movie in this during this time but
yet you're right there were like scenes
that kind of just felt like mini
sketches
um but that's I think just
like what the audience would have wanted
from them being on SNL oh I think like
the kind of movie it is and the kind of
movie was especially from back then it
sort of makes sense and Lauren Michaels
uh producing this film as well like yeah
you know you sort of expect that but it
still it still goes above and beyond to
have a some good messages and character
growth he literally goes from like Tommy
Boy to Tommy Man by the end of the film
there was a full character art guys for
both of him and David Spade both of them
yeah because his that that whole scene
what he is learning about the sales I
actually thought that was really clever
where you they do have a good something
that's kind of surprisingly poignant
about how you know in life a lot of
people
a lot of times in life people feel a
little bit held down by how they
performed in school you know their their
formal education but there's so much
more to succeeding in life uh you know
based off of how you feel internally who
you are as a person developing
confidence developing Street smarts and
people skills like that usually can
outweigh so much of an academic
experience not to Discount an academic
experience but that is something that's
very it doesn't Define you exactly so I
thought that was a surprising
yeah surprisingly good message and and
for for the boy who comes from such a
wealthy family who's a very spoiled and
God and everything given to him he he
managed to truly find you know even
though people clown on himself but it
was still like a real Underdog Story
where you find yourself sort of rooting
for this buffoon which I was surprised
by because it could have easily like I
said it could have easily just been an
annoying movie but it didn't amount to
that and David Spade was newspaper was
good too you know it's like when you
step into a role like that you're you're
aware that I can't compete with Chris
Farley so that's right yeah I'm here to
support Chris Farley because if they
were both like super over the top I
don't think it would have worked you
know but like the fact that David Spade
played it pretty straight the whole time
is kind of what made it funny yeah um
because you're waiting to see how he'll
respond and like how he'll react to
Chris to you know Tommy was probably his
character he still had some funny
moments though that uh I still think
that he there's some good deliveries and
stuff but I thought the word of
friendship is great insults that's the
spade for you but the I thought the I
thought the way their friendship
um formed felt natural and it's also
nice to get kind of a
I don't know you know normally in in
comedies nowadays Everything feels so
like such high stakes
comedy especially with the Buddy movies
they usually have like some kind of
action element involved in them now too
and to get a movie plot that's about
you know the Simplicity of saving a
family business and but it's like you're
going into all these these this talk
about stuff and cars yeah automobile
industry that is so specific like it
seemed like they really had to know what
they were talking about to a certain
degree when making this film and I was
surprised by like this is I've never
really seen a movie that deals so much
with with this whole I think industry I
think that's what grounded it because
that might be why it's such a classic
comedy movie because like it is very
different but you're right it's all very
like it feel like I forgot I was
watching a movie when it was they were
having the scenes about you know like
the business and everything because I'm
just like oh yeah like I was like
genuinely trying to like listen to
everything and you believed like even
all the extras like looked like it legit
looked like uh there's some movies you
watch where extras look like extras you
know what I mean yeah but
um like they look fake people like a
fake town or whatever but they generally
look like a real like small town you
know like they could work in a factory
and I think that helped too yeah weirdly
really well done I I don't know why
I don't know what's expecting but like
the production value on this was was
actually really good I was surprised by
that there were so many sets and animals
and real yeah they think I'm like
wow they really use locations yeah the
deer the deer definitely was like a
probably a puppet maybe even with one
like that that quick scene of them like
when they were about to hit it looked
like a slight animatronic
um and and then after that it was like a
real deal so I was like whoa like I
didn't at this was obviously before like
good CGI
um so they had to get really creative
but it weirdly made it seem more
realistic and I I enjoyed that it was
kind of fun even the moths I was just
like so fixated in the scene staring at
it because I'm like I know those aren't
real moths but they looked like they
were all flying in that corner I'm like
how are they doing that
um yeah I don't know isn't that weird
that we're so used to CGI that like I
just like really hyper focused on that
wow yeah I know that was very I was I
find myself thinking about those things
too uh especially for from the 80s where
you feel like they would want to go a
little bit cheaper but I'm like they
threw down for this movie they did they
really need to look real and and I like
the
I just like how they they really seem
like they mapped there's a lot of
there's a lot of good visual comedy in
here and but you know it's all like
everything goes back to Chris Farley at
the end of the day in this film you know
yeah I don't think anyone else could
have played this character there is such
a there is such like a Wonder in his
eyes there and like as as high octane
energy as he is like I really feel like
sometimes a personality like that can be
a little off-putting and yeah yeah he's
so Charming you know and I think I don't
know how he does that I really don't
because I feel like any other person
that would try to play that off would
kind of come across creepy like how how
are you like how do you look like a
toddler but then also like have a child
like Wonder but then also you you can
act like an adult like it's just kind of
it's a fine line but he Nails it and
that's why he's a legend
let's uh I'm gonna read a couple of
facts for you oh okay well I just pulled
these up right now because
I just thought this was interesting Rob
Lowe played the supporting role of
Tommy's stepbrother but is uncredited
the reason for this is because he wanted
it to be a happy surprise after the
script shifted Focus
because the film was originally centered
around the relationship between Tommy
and Rob Lowe's character Paul
so
for some reason he wanted it to
he has to not be credited that's a weird
thing
huh I don't know but apparently was that
a weird way of him being like I don't
want to be a part of this movie no no no
I think he wanted it to be some surprise
for some reason I don't know what the
surprise is for though
but anyway yeah that's interesting hey
check this out I've I've never well
first I I've just never watched Rob Lowe
and something where I was like creeped
out by him but like for some reason he
creeped me out of this he's done some
creepy things in real life too he's a
he's a questionable person sometimes oh
I read his book but whatever oh you read
his whole book yeah
I mean it was it never ends
so all right on the list showing the
exam grades of the students at the
beginning of the movie
look at the bottom uh this is when he
got to when he gets his D plus right one
of the names is Helen Keller who scored
an F
and to the right of Helen Keller is
Michael Jackson who also got a d-plus
isn't that interesting well
uh whoa okay I got a long one for you
during filming David's fading Chris
Farley got into a physical altercation
on set
there's a whole explanation to here oh
there are times I just really didn't get
along really wow that's surprising
apparently there was some that
happened where they they didn't get
along
interesting whoa but I don't think I
would have picked up I didn't pick up on
that at all so they're great actors I
mean they've worked together again and
they've they've definitely had an
endearing friendship over the years
buried the hatchet but during this film
apparently they didn't get along a lot
of the time maybe sometimes when
someone's that big of a character your
initial reaction could be to get annoyed
you know
um if you're not used to working with
someone like that so I'm sure he
probably just wasn't used to working
with him so closely
for that long
what happened this is gnarly okay here
we go I'm going to read this super quick
pay attention Sally pay attention as
they landed in Toronto on an early
Sunday morning after doing SNL in New
York Farley was not feeling well so he
went up to his hotel room Spade not
thinking about it had called the Rob
Lowe and they went out to a bar for a
drink Farley found out the next morning
and had become very jealous and
throughout the morning would angrily
stare at spade and repeatedly ask him
how's Rob Lowe
Spade try to explain and reminded him
word off the wire was that you were sick
but Farley wasn't hearing it later that
day they were about to shoot a scene
Spade was sitting on the ground eating a
tuna sandwich and going over his lines
while Farley smoking a cigarette was
still just staring and asking him how's
Rob Lowe Spade was getting annoyed with
him at this point Farley then went over
to spade and stomped on his hand with
this sandwich in it oh my God fade
responded by throwing his diet coke on
him to which Farley threw Spade into a
wall and pushed him down a small set of
steps before things got too violent the
walkie-talkie called action they quickly
composed themselves and walked in the
set then when it was time for Spade to
say his line he couldn't speak so he
stormed offset into the trailer the
director called cut and Farley went off
to his trailer too Spade refused to
continue filming with Farley Farley was
so mad that he needed to hit someone so
he tackled the director's assistant
Skippy the parents sometimes go for
hours without talking to each other they
would talk to each other through the
director that is insane Rob Lowe you
teared up a friendship on set sometimes
Lisa I didn't know I mean okay so we had
an anger issue that makes sense
yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely but is he
still a legend though should I take that
back who
Chris Farley as far as of course the
legend okay well I would I don't know
you like assaulted people
back then they're two men people
wouldn't cry over something like this
and be like men fighting that's what
happened yeah but I've fallen downstairs
before it is not fun there's a small set
of stairs just small yeah you're right
but he was he was completely sober
during addiction though that's crazy uh
during filming I mean it was completely
over time
and I was like huh yeah okay but he
developed a coffee addiction filming
this movie oh wow there's some amazing
things yeah I could see that yeah that's
where I got his energy I thought it was
all natural yeah yeah
wow wow okay there's a lot of facts here
there's so many to go over I'm gonna
become obsessed with learning everything
about dogs what did the movie do well
commercially at least or did it flop uh
I mean I know it's uh I know now it's a
cult classic box office hit
uh it did okay I guess it did well and
oh yeah yeah I did well profited okay
yeah
um but it's more considered like a cult
classic more than anything yeah but all
right yeah that was a fun film what was
it on Paramount plus this whole time no
no I would have had Paramount all right
I don't have Paramount plus so well yeah
I mean it's like the one I don't have
okay I use it once a month
tied not even a show I'm just like oh
apparently this thing is I forget I have
Paramount plus I get a lot of
subscriptions through my Amazon account
because you can like link up so right
I'm always like I forgot to cancel
Showtime like that's my life oh I've
done that before for school that was
annoying but uh here we are all right
Sally well what do you give it out of
10.
um you know an ex
boyfriend of mine
we were seeing each other and he was mad
that I hadn't seen this movie and that's
why we broke up so I give it
well it's a healthy relationship no I'm
kidding him I mean he was kind of mad so
something about this healed me you know
it closed the chapter for me so I'd give
it a
I give it an 8 out of ten perfect pick
up that phone you call that man back
I'll call him and you let him say hey I
finally watched it are you free to watch
another movie oh yes
is there a Tommy Boy too
I don't think so
all righty guys well check out Sally's
if you just made it this long you're a
good person so check out Sally's
Spider-Man Kickstarter do you sneeze
you fart what was that
coughing and I know you've said things a
few times I cough but like I'm still
getting over this awful virus so
I apologize
support Sally has uh she needs this
charity for the hospital visits how do I
see yeah I was supposed to say how do I
sell this so I say I'm homeless
um I'm a homeless person trying to make
a fan film come here and film here guys
this is gonna be my big break because I
can't profit off of it because it's
copier in material that is true that is
true you're doing this other kindness
for your heart I really am all right
ladies and gentlemen we'll talk with you
soon Sally thank you for gracing us with
your wonderful lovely presence
thank you for having me Greg it was
great laughing with you peace out reject
Nation peace out
[Music]